kleine quizfrage was kann fahren darf
aber nicht ihr euro für diesel wald
und was darf an kann aber nicht die
deutsche bahn will man mit dem kalauer
direkt im thema der aufsichtsrat der
deutschen bahn hatte gerade mal wieder
krisensitzung nur jeder fünfte ic ist
gerade voll funktionsfähig es fehlen
mindestens 5800 mitarbeiter bei der bahn
und das mit den verspätungen wird auch
nicht besser kannst du den nicht
schönreden es sei denn du bist an die
scheuer
ich glaube mit der mobilität in
deutschland wenn man das weltweit
vergleich kann man sehr zufrieden sein
spiel weltweit gereist ich bin aus
indien gekommen alles war pünktlich und
kommt in frankfurt am bahnhof an und
darf er dazu nicht so einfach gute
nachher wirklich das kann man doch gar
nicht vergleichen indien in indien
dürfen die passagiere auf dem dach
mitfahren sind völlig andere geschichte
und bei uns in deutschland heißt es
leider immer öfter ich stehe nur bahnhof
im oktober waren gerade einmal 73
prozent der züge in deutschland
pünktlich
die bahn bleibt zwar bei ihrem
anvisierten ziel von 82 prozent
wirkliche züge hat dieses ziel jetzt
vertagt auf das jahr 2025 zu viel
ehrgeiz ist auch nicht gesund und
pünktlichkeit eine definitionssache
dabei hat die db eine eigene definition
erfunden bis zu einer verspätung von
fünf minuten und 59 sekunden ist ein zug
offiziell pünktlich wiener waldorfschule
die wahl wurde kaputt gespart und leidet
unter einem investitionsstau von
mindestens 50 milliarden euro
gleichzeitig darf sie aber nur knapp 20
milliarden schulden machen und ist als
unternehmen verpflichtet gewinn zu
erzielen ja warum eigentlich
die klatsche gehört doch eher den start
was soll das jetzt haben die gute
nachricht zumindest im kampf gegen
verspätung ist man einen guten schritt
weiter gekommen und zwar dank ja
bahnvorstand ronald pofalla meine damen
und herren
ja ja ja kennen sie noch die alte
schlägertyp die damals wolfgang bosbach
die fresse polieren wollte hatte
wirklich eine fantastische idee ganz
ehrlich für mich ist es die
wahrscheinlich größte erfindung seit dem
feuer dem rad und dem sandwich toaster
die pofalla wende die gibt es wirklich
ist kein witz mal angenommen eine fahrt
von köln nach dortmund unter zugführer
merkt in bochum scheiße wir haben ja
noch mehr verspätung als sonst dann
macht er eine pofalla wende
das heißt kein witz erfährt kann nicht
mehr bis dortmund sondern verlässt die
bahn steigt hinten wieder ein und fährt
einfach zurück nach köln
das ist natürlich blöd für die menschen
in dortmund war der ece kommt da gar
nicht mehr hin
aber auf dem rückweg ist ja wieder
pünktlich einfach aufgeben übrigens auch
praktisch in anderen lebensbereichen
wenn beim fußball er schon 0 5 zurück
liegst und schießt ein eigentor
wenn es bei der blinddarm op
komplikationen gibt patient zu nehmen
und nach hause gehen und natürlich beim
sex wenn du merkst das wird eh nix mehr
mach einfach die profiler wende
keine sportchef
[Applaus]
nico faller wende
der pokal ist zugegeben der bund
investiert im nächsten jahr 5,6
milliarden ins schienennetz aber 10,8
milliarden entfernt straßen das ist eine
relativ seltsame gewichtung in zeiten
des klimawandels viel mehr leute müssten
zug fahren und die deutschen sollten der
bahn finde ich in dieser krise beistehen
hol dir jetzt die work and travel
bahncard nutzlos herumstehen und auf den
zug warten war gestern packt mit an und
hilft als kunde deine bahn in stand zu
halten ja ich bin eigentlich
versicherungskaufmann ich werde jeden
tag zwei stunden auch mal zu und habe
ich mir gedacht in der zeit kann ich das
super die weichen reinigt balkan zu ja
mein anschluss zur es kaputt und
deswegen fahre ich den schnell selber in
die werkstatt
deutsche bahn wir haben so wenig
personal
wir nehmen quasi jeden
red
ja
und dann
da kann wirklich jeder helfen ich habe
auch schon opfer gebracht
so heißt das doch wenn man zweiter
klasse fährt oder habe ich nie gemacht
manchmal schon im ersten quartal 2009/10
müssen deutliche verbesserungen kommen
bei der bahn sagt minister scheuer wir
schalten mal live in die nagelneue db
leitstelle in berlin von der ost
alexander wipprecht den gesamten
zugverkehr koordiniert wird recht wie
will die bahn denn die wende schaffen ja
ein wort digitalisierung die deutsche
bahn die ist so kurz vor dem sprung ins
zwanzigste jahrhundert
sie meint 121 von 120 1 am andern 27
unser stellwerke laufen noch mechanisch
also von hand da fällt mir ein ich muss
mal ganz kurz eine weiche umstellen
sekunde
[Musik]
sonst gibt's wieder tote in potsdam
kein witz das ist teilweise noch technik
aus der kaiserzeit william der tote hoch
hoch hoch
ja herr werke wir werden hier bald
milliarden in die elektrifizierung
investieren 40 prozent der deutschen
bahn strecken die sind noch nicht
elektrifiziert wir kriegen bald strom
[Musik]
sorry ja zwischen köln und frankfurt
brennt ein ece schon wieder gut wie
stark brennt der den ach so nur der
speisewagen nähe soll weiter fahren
nächste regen geben na ja entschuldigung
sie hatten das gefragt ja was soll die
wende bringen
gott kann mir nicht mal das positive
sehen bestehen in sachen pünktlichkeit
vor litauen und außerdem führen wir bald
den sogenannten deutschlandpakt einen da
fahren züge dann immer in den gleichen
verlässlichen abständen von 60 oder 30
minuten das heißt ich weiß das klingt
jetzt wie science fiction
ich glaube an und er würde in jedem fall
meinen anschlusszug geilomat wow das hat
die schweiz seit 1982 aber wir haben das
ab 2030 so was kompliziert ist das für
uns ja nicht mal eben so hopplahopp 1
da braucht man eben die entsprechende
technik also jetzt zum beispiel uhren
mit zwei zeiger das kann doch alles viel
zu spät warum hat die bahn solange
gepennt und gespart wo ja jetzt aber
immer langsam mit den jungen pferden ich
sage immer so ein alter idee ist noch
lange kein geht's hoch
moment der kompakte ja jetzt haben ein
problem der ece grause von stuttgart
nach köln der iss pünktlich da ist
bringt jetzt den ganzen takt auseinander
bremsen bremse wagen reihung ändern und
sofort pofalla wende einleiten pofalla
wende einleiten alexander verbrechen
damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]